Prof: Last time I
discussed the planet as a
basically physical and chemical
machine,
and how climate affects
temperature and water and
nutrient relationships on the
planet,
both on the continents and in
the ocean.
And what that does is it
creates a mosaic of ecological
problems for organisms.
And the part of ecology that
looks at how organisms
individually deal with the
problems posed by the
environment,
things like temperature and pH
and water availability and stuff
like that,
is called physiological ecology.
And I'm going to give you a
brief description of that today,
using a historical framework,
which is up here on the first
slide.
Now the purpose of this
historical framework is to show
you that between about 1860 and
about 1960 people conceptualized
both the way the organisms deal
with these problems in the
environment,
and then how to integrate that
into a comprehensive vision of
where organisms can live,
and why that is the case.
And that vision of where
organisms can live and
reproduce,
survive and reproduce,
the ecological niche idea,
is something that turned into
an intellectual tool that became
very useful in many different
parts of ecology.
So what we're doing here is
starting off with Claude
Bernard,
the great French physiologist
who came up with the idea that
one of the basic things going on
in organisms is that they're
trying to keep their inside
constant,
while the outside changes;
the idea of homeostasis,
la constance du milieu
intérieur.
And well then I'll briefly
mention L.J. Henderson,
who said, "You know,
it's extremely interesting that
the properties of important
things in the environment,
like water and air and the
molecules out of which organisms
are built,
and things like that,
are in some cases extremely
convenient for life."
He called that the fitness of
the environment.
So he kind of turned the whole
idea of evolutionary fitness
around,
and he said,
"The environment appears
to be peculiarly fit,
as a place for organisms,
like the ones that we know,
to live in."
And, of course,
that's not too surprising,
given that this is the planet
on which life evolved.
Nevertheless,
it's worth considering the fact
that water has some completely
extraordinary properties.
It has very high heat capacity.
It transfers heat very rapidly,
and water can put into solution
probably more different kinds of
atoms and molecules than almost
any other solvent.
So on a planetary scale,
water serves very effectively
as a heat transfer mechanism;
what we saw in the lecture last
time.
It serves very effectively as a
medium in which a huge diversity
of chemical reactions can occur,
out of which life has selected
some of them,
and so forth.
And you can carry this kind of
thinking on, into other parts of
biology.
For example,
why is it that phosphorus was
the element that was selected to
be the medium of biological
energy transfer in the form of
ATP?
And if you look into the shell
structure of the phosphorous
atom,
you will find that it actually
has some options for storing
energy,
and then forming bonds with
oxygen,
that help us to understand why
it was phosphorous that was the
one that life selected for the
generalized unit of energy
currency.
So L.J. Henderson's ideas
actually are kind of provocative
and interesting,
and the book,
The Fitness of the
Environment,
is well written and a pleasure
to read.
So if you get interested in
that--and by the way,
Claude Bernard's book,
A Study of Experimental
Medicine,
is easily available in English.
These people are very bright
people who wrote some classics,
and it's nice to be able,
as a scholar,
to tap into that history of the
development of ideas.
Now the culmination of this,
at least for today's purposes,
was Evelyn Hutchinson's
concluding remarks at the Cold
Spring Harbor Symposium on Long
Island in 1959.
That was the output of his
graduate seminar here in this
department where he had--
in his graduate seminar at that
time he had people like Larry
Slobodkin and Bob MacArthur and
Alan Kohn.
So there was kind of a dynamic
group of grad students in the
Yale Biology Department,
studying ecology at that time,
and they had come up,
together with Hutchinson,
with this idea of the niche as
an N-dimensional hyper-volume.
And that was a very powerful
tool for condensing all of these
ideas about how individual
organisms and populations are
dealing with their physical and
chemical environments,
and representing it as an
object that then could be used
further in analysis.
So that's the framework.
These are the guys,
Bernard, Henderson and
Hutchinson.
There's a portrait of
Hutchinson in the Saybrook
Dining Hall.
I actually think the photo's a
little bit better.
This is a bush baby;
that's a Galago.
I wouldn't mind having one of
those.
And the outline of the lecture
is going to be a bit about
temperature and about thermal
regulation.
So the basic idea here is that
ectotherms and endotherms have
really quite different problems
with temperature,
and they deal with it in quite
different ways.
In homeotherms,
we're going to look at
metabolic rate and brown fat and
hibernation, and why it is that
intermediate sized things
hibernate.
The really little ones can't
and the really big ones can't,
but the ones in the middle can.
We'll take a bit of a look at
temperature and evaporative
water loss,
and then I want to talk a bit
about how plants deal with
drought and with too little
water and oxygen,
and then we'll end up with the
ecological niche.
This is a very,
very quick and kind of spotty
summary of some major themes in
physiological ecology.
It's a big field,
and it contains a lot of neat
experiments, and I'm only able
to touch on it quickly in this
course.
One of the themes that I want
to bring up now--
and I hope I remember to come
back and mention it again later
in the lecture--
is that we will see that
organisms have lots of
adaptations for dealing with the
external environment.
We'll see it in the nose and
the brain of the oryx,
and we'll see it in the special
organs of plants to deal with
oxygen problems and so forth.
And one way to think about that
is that evolution has designed
organisms to extend the range of
environments in which they can
survive and reproduce,
and therefore that the
definition of what is critical
in the environment has been
continually changed by
evolution.
It's been a moving target.
You cannot think of an
ecological niche as being
something that pre-existed on
the planet, before life started
to evolve.
But we now use,
as a tool in ecology,
the concept of the ecological
nice as an artificial construct,
invented by human minds,
as an intellectual tool to try
to make sense out of the
complexity of nature.
And our definition of it
actually is the product of
evolution, and it's been a
moving target.
So don't think of the
environment as consisting of a
pre-existing chessboard on one
of which- each square of which
is a niche,
and into which you can put an
organism,
and then it will all get filled
up.
Because the organisms
themselves have been defining
what these things are,
as they evolve.
Okay, a little bit about
ectotherms and endotherms.
Here's, on the X-axis,
we've got environmental
temperature, outside
temperature, in Centigrade;
and here we have body
temperature.
And a mouse is maintaining its
temperature at a nice 37,
and the lizard is letting its
temperature fluctuate with the
external environment.
We'll see that actually lizards
can control this,
to some extent,
behaviorally,
and that things like mice,
of course, do have daily
temperature cycles and so forth.
But just at this level--and
it's a very rough
contrast--endotherms maintain
constant internal temperature
and ectotherms let it fluctuate.
Now lizards have a preferred
temperature, and actually their
preferred temperature is a bit
hotter than the mouse.
They like it to be oh about
30--well maybe not quite as hot
as the mouse,
but they like it in the
mid-30s;
so say around somewhere between
90 and 95 Fahrenheit,
say 88 and 95.
And their surroundings have a
huge temperature range,
and the actual temperature
range--this is what you would
measure in the lab.
If you made a temperature
gradient,
and you put your lizard in and
you let it just settle down in
the temperature gradient,
it would wander back and forth
until it found what it liked,
and it would settle down right
there.
Its actual temperature in
nature is much narrower than the
range of temperatures out there
in the environment.
And, for example,
it can do things like having
its back facing east or its back
facing west, depending upon
whether it's morning or
afternoon.
Right at noon,
when the sun's directly
overhead, it won't orient like
that.
So if the lizards are basking,
they bask in such a way that
helps them to maintain their
actual temperature above that of
the environment,
in this case.
They manage to be warm when
they need to run fast,
and they manage to be cool at
night.
If you're a herpetologist and
you like to catch lizards,
you know that a lizard that's
been sitting on a nice warm rock
is going to run away from you
really quickly when you try to
go up and grab it.
And, of course,
they have developed this
because they need to get away
from predators.
So they will bask in the
morning, to get their
temperature up,
and then they will move back
and forth between sun and shade
during the day,
to maintain their body
temperature,
in the high 30s,
and then they go back into
their burrow at night.
So there is a kind of
behavioral thermoregulation in
this ectotherm,
which is not doing its
thermoregulation with internal
physiology;
it's doing it by moving in and
out of sun and shade.
Another very important idea for
ectotherms,
and particularly for small
ones--the smaller you are,
because of the surface area
volume ratio,
the more rapidly you take up or
lose heat.
This idea is physiological time.
Okay?
So physiological time is
something which is really
directly proportional to
temperature;
and you can see an illustration
of it over here.
This is the percentage of
development that's going on in
the course of one day.
So in 24 hours this is how much
development is occurring in
standardized stages,
depending upon temperature.
And if you transform that into
a rate per day and plot it
against temperature,
you get this nice straight
line, which basically means that
time is directly proportional to
temperature.
So the hotter it is,
the faster they'll develop.
And what that means is kind of
interesting for ecology,
because on the one hand you've
got a lot of predators who are
homeotherms,
and who don't have this kind of
reaction at all.
So they're running around
rapidly.
Shrews, mice, birds;
lots of things that will eat
insects are fairly insensitive
to the external temperature,
and they can be active at all
temperatures.
Whereas the insects are
actually forced,
by their small size and their
ectotherm status,
to grow more slowly when it's
cold,
and they're forced to grow more
rapidly when it's hot.
And that has cascading effects
on their population dynamics and
on their predator/prey
relations.
Now what about endotherms,
how do they deal with the
environmental temperature?
Well this is the body
temperature of a model
endotherm, and this is its heat
production here.
Now what's going on is that
there is an upper critical
temperature,
and if the environmental
in the long-term,
goes above this upper critical
temperature,
the endotherm can no longer
thermoregulate,
and its body temperature will
rise.
If I take you out into the
Sahara,
on a hot day,
and I sit you down,
you're going to thermoregulate
pretty well,
until the external temperature
gets above about a steady 110,
or something like that,
Fahrenheit,
and at that point your sweating
and so forth isn't going to
function anymore,
and your body temperature will
rise,
and if that goes on very long
you'll be dead.
So that's what this critical
temperature means.
Lower critical temperature.
Basically if the environmental
temperature drops below the
lower critical temperature,
then internal heat production
starts to ramp up.
That would be both direct
burning of fat,
down at the cellular level,
and it would be shivering,
and things like that.
And that would allow you to
maintain a nice steady internal
temperature,
until you got down to your
maximum heat output,
by all physiological mechanisms
combined,
and if the external temperature
drops even further than that,
and you're no longer able to
keep up,
you will freeze and die down at
that end.
Okay?
So you can see that there is a
range of environmental values
that can be dealt with,
and then outside that range you
can't deal with it anymore.
And this is something that's
evolved, where these points are.
So what's going on here is
variations among different kinds
of endotherms in their
insulation blood flow,
how they select microclimates,
shivering and huddling.
Insulation.
Take a Weddell seal or a
Leopard seal or something like
that, freeze it,
cut it in half with a band saw,
look at it in cross-section.
It's about one-third fat,
on the outside.
It's extremely well insulated.
Same thing for a humpback whale
or a blue whale.
So insulation can be very
important.
Bears do it.
We do it;
we have subcutaneous fat that
serves as an insulator.
Shivering and huddling;
well you know all about
shivering.
Huddling is something,
for example,
that the emperor penguins do.
Emperor penguins have this
totally bizarre lifestyle where
they have chosen to lay their
eggs on part of the Antarctic
continent,
which is exposed during the
summer,
but their lifecycle is such
that it takes them about six
months for the eggs to hatch and
then to start to feed baby.
And so at the time when they
have these little chicks that
need lots of warmth,
and they are shuttling back and
forth to try to go way out to
the edge of the pack ice to get
squid--
because now it's winter and the
pack ice is frozen-they huddle
and get into a big circle where
you'll have hundreds of these
giant penguins--
they're about this big--that
are all packed together.
And the Antarctic hurricanes
are blowing over them with -40,
-50 Fahrenheit temperatures,
and the birds are basically
forming a continually moving
clump in which the ones on the
outside are getting desperate
and pushing their way into the
inside,
and the ones on the inside,
they're a little bit warmer and
not quite so desperate,
and are getting pushed out to
the outside.
So that's huddling.
Okay, now let's go inside some
organisms and look at some of
the adaptations that evolution
has produced that allow them to
regulate their internal
environment.
So this is a classic example of
something that would cause the
internal environment to be held
constant,
despite great variation in the
external environment:
countercurrent heat exchangers.
And the way these things work
basically is that if you have
concurrent flow--
this is the countercurrent
case, and it's being explained
here by contrast to the
concurrent case.
In concurrent flow you would
have say venous blood going in
this direction;
and then running right next to
the vein you've got an artery,
going in this direction.
So the artery perhaps is nice
and warm,
but it's running next to the
vein, and there's an exchange
gradient along it,
and as these two things
exchange heat they end up at the
same temperature,
coming out.
That's what happens if the flow
is going in the same direction.
But if you arrange it
physiologically,
and morphologically,
so that the flow in the artery
is going in the opposite
direction to the flow in the
vein--
so this is going into the organ
and this is coming out of the
organ,
going back to the heart--then
what goes on is that the blood
that's coming in,
in the artery,
is getting heated by the blood
that's going back out in the
vein,
and that's going to maintain
the temperature on this side.
Now which way you would want to
set this up would depend upon
whether you wanted the warmth to
be in the core of the body or in
the outside of the body.
In most cases,
this is in the core of the
body.
You guys have got this,
right here.
You can walk in water,
and a countercurrent heat
exchanger in your legs will make
sure that your body core doesn't
drop temperature too much.
Yours is okay,
but it's not really nearly as
impressive as the ones that are
in the feet of ducks and geese
and moose and things like that;
that can stand around in water,
which is right at the freezing
point, and their core body
temperature stays a nice stable
98.
Okay?
Let me just mention,
before I go into the oryx,
that there are countercurrent
exchangers that deal with ion
concentrations in vertebrate
kidneys--
so the vertebrate kidney is
actually designed using this
same principle--
and with oxygen concentration
in fish gills.
So countercurrent exchangers
are something that is obviously
such a good engineering idea
that it has been arrived at
convergently by evolution to
deal with similar problems,
but completely independently
solved.
Let's take a look at one.
This is the desert oryx--really
a beautiful animal,
I've seen them in Namibia--and
we're going to look inside its
head here.
So the problem that the oryx
has is that it needs to regulate
both its temperature and its
water supply.
It's living in the desert.
And if you look into its head,
it's got a lot of exposure of
its blood supply to external air
coming in.
It doesn't want to lose too
much water by sweating.
So what it's done is it's
allowed its body temperature to
go up to 44 degrees Centigrade.
So it won't regulate its body
temperature until it hits 44
degrees Centigrade.
And it's a big animal,
so overnight it can cool down,
and it'll take a long time to
hit 44, during the day.
But its brain would die if it
ever got to 44 Centigrade.
So it has to figure out a way,
how to hold its brain at a nice
39 degrees,
while its body temperature,
which has most of its blood
supply in it,
is at 44.
So it's got to drop that body
temperature by about 5 degrees
Centigrade going into the brain.
And the way it does it is it
first takes the blood and it
gets cooled.
So there's blood that's being
pumped out,
into its nose--it has a great
big nose--
blood is getting pumped out
into its nose and coming back
through these veins.
And this is cold
because--colder--because of the
evaporative processes that are
going on in the nose.
It gets passed through what is
called a rete mirabile,
right here, and the oxygenated
blood,
which is going to go into the
brain,
passes through this,
and the cold blood coming out
of the nose cools the oxygenated
blood off before it gets into
the brain.
It's really a beautiful
adaptation, and it's something
that gets repeated in other
organisms to solve similar
problems in other situations.
For example, tuna.
Here are some yellowfin tuna,
and they have a countercurrent
heat exchanger,
and they use it to keep cold
sea water from chilling their
warm venous blood that's coming
out of their hot high
performance muscle.
So they cannot really retain
very much heat overall,
because in order to get oxygen
out of the water,
they're pumping--and they're
very high energy animals,
so they're pumping a lot of
oxygen through their gills.
And that is a big surface.
The water has,
as I mentioned with Henderson,
very high heat capacity and a
great ability to strip heat off
of the blood supply in the
gills.
But down the core of their body
they've got some dark muscle
that they want to keep up at 37
degrees Centigrade,
so that they can do things like
swim from San Francisco to Tokyo
in seven days,
at speeds of up to 50
kilometers an hour.
These fish are amazing.
Well what they've done--this is
sort of a perch or a largemouth
bass.
And you might think of that as
the ancestral condition,
and they've taken this
ancestral condition,
where the vein,
coming back into the heart,
looks like that,
and the dorsal aorta going out
of the heart looks like that,
and that kind of circulation
has been altered so that you
have a rete mirabile between
arteries that are running out
under the surface of the skin,
and veins that are running out
under the surface of the skin.
And when these arteries are
then pumping through the rete
mirabile,
into the core of the animal,
they are picking up heat that's
being generated by that muscle
tissue,
and then in the countercurrent
heat exchanger,
or the rete mirabile,
that heat is exchanged,
going back into the veins.
So on the external part of the
body the blood's right at
environmental temperature,
and in the core of the body,
it is probably maintained at
anywhere from 10 to 20 degrees
Centigrade above the
environmental temperatures,
so that these very efficient
muscles can work.
Mammals maintain their internal
temperature, particularly small
mammals, maintain their internal
temperature using something
called brown fat.
So this is now not a
morphological adaptation,
at the level of an organ--which
is what the rete mirabile or the
countercurrent heat exchanger
are--
this is a cellular adaptation.
So if you take a cute little
eastern chipmunk and you look
into its body,
you find that there are
specific places where it has
deposits of brown fat.
And this is what brown fat
looks like under a microscope.
This is white fat.
Okay?
This is what I've got hanging
on my belly.
And in a brown squirrel,
they have,
above the kidney and in the
back of the neck and so forth,
brown fat, and the reason it's
brown is that it's loaded with
mitochondria.
And so if they get a signal
that the temperature's dropping,
and that comes into their
brain, into their hypothalamus,
they will put out a hormone
that carries a hormonal signal
out to their brown fat,
and the mitochondria in the
brown fat receiving that signal
will start to simply generate
energy,
and that generates heat.
Okay?
This is actually the mechanism
that allows hibernation,
because they can regulate that
heat generation up or down.
And hibernation is something
which is done in mammals,
of course, to avoid dying,
in the winter.
I have, I think,
three or four eastern chipmunks
that live in my yard in Hamden,
and they tend to disappear
towards the end of September,
and I'll probably first see
them again sometime during the
next month.
They've been down for several
months.
Okay?
They're all wrapped up in a
ball underground,
sleeping away.
And you can only do that if
you're kind of an intermediate
size.
So when it's preparing for
hibernation, it's regulating its
temperature near 37.
Then when it's down in the
ground, it will drop it,
down to about 10 degrees.
And it's got a temperature
sensor, in its brain,
which keeps it from freezing.
In other words,
the temperature will go down to
about 10, or maybe a little bit
below in some other small
mammals, but it will never go to
freezing.
So it can tell if it's getting
dangerously cold,
and it will regulate its lower
temperature with the brown fat,
so it doesn't completely
freeze.
And they do wake up a little
bit sometimes during the winter,
but they don't really come out.
They'll wake up and roll over,
and if they have stored seed
underground, they will go eat
their seed stores so they can
keep doing this.
And then right about now
they'll come out again.
So what's going on in one bout
of hibernation here--
so if we just take one little
bout here--
they drop their metabolic rate,
they drop their body
temperature,
and for about a week they have
a very low metabolic rate and a
low body temperature;
it's down, in Centigrade,
it can get down to maybe 3 or 4
degrees.
And then they will arouse,
eat and then do it again.
So this is regulated actually
both by physiology and by
behavior;
and by morphology.
They have pouches in their
cheeks where they can store the
seeds,
and they have a seed deposit in
their burrow,
and when they wake up and they
need to recharge,
that's what they use,
and then their physiology takes
over;
and that's what gets them
through the winter.
Now you can imagine that this
has greatly extended the
geographical range in which
something like a chipmunk can
live.
Now I want you to think about
the surface area to volume
ratios for a minute.
I think you all know that the
surface area is proportional to
the square of a body dimension,
and the volume of an organism
is proportional to the cube of a
body dimension,
so that when things get big,
they have proportionally less
surface area,
and when they get small they
have proportionally more surface
area.
And I want you just to take a
minute and explain to your
partner why it is that really
small things can't hibernate,
and really big things can't
hibernate.
And let's see how you do,
and I'll give you the answer in
about two minutes.
<<Students confer with
one another>>
Student:  How do bears
hibernate?
Prof: They don't.
Student:  They don't?
Prof: They sleep.
Yes Myra?
Student:  We learned
that bears hibernate--
Prof: Bears don't
hibernate, they sleep.
A very bad idea to try to take
the body temperature of a
sleeping brown bear.
It can wake up in a hurry.
A chipmunk can't wake up.
Student:  Oh.
Prof: You can pick a
chipmunk up and toss it in your
hand, it won't wake up.
You go in and try to take the
rectal temperature of a brown
bear and you better be ready to
run in a hurry.
Student:  What is the
difference between hibernating
and sleeping?
Prof: How far the body
temperature will drop.
A bear--your body temperature
drops when you sleep;
it goes from about 98.6 down to
about 96 or 95,
and then it warms back up when
you wake up.
A bear might drop down to about
90.
A chipmunk will drop to 40.
Okay, who can tell me why
really small things can't
hibernate?
Like shrews,
which I have in my garage,
in the middle of the winter.
Okay, why do really small
things not hibernate?
What's their problem with
surface area and volume?
Student:  Their surface
area is really big compared to
their volume.
So there's a lot of surface
to--
Prof: Right.
So even though evolution has
done a great job of developing
these temperature regulating
mechanisms,
there comes a point at which
they can no longer do it,
and if you get really small,
there's just no way that you
can build say a 20 gram shrew
that will be able to regulate
its temperature.
It just has too much surface
area.
Okay?
What about something that's big?
I've heard a couple of comments
about bears;
bears are big.
Okay?
Bears don't hibernate,
they sleep.
Why can the bear not hibernate?
Remember, hibernation is a
condition where you really drop
your body temperature a lot.
Yes?
Student:  Maybe its
volume to surface ratio is
larger, and so it has
>
Prof: Yes,
it can't get rid of the heat
fast enough to drop its body
temperature.
So just a bunch of kind of
torpid bear fat,
if it's alive,
is still making enough
temperature.
So it can't radiate it off fast
enough.
So that's basically why you get
these rough limits.
Even in something which is as
ectothermic as my compost heap
in the backyard,
whose temperature is being
regulated by bacteria and fungi,
I can go out there when it's 20
degrees below 0,
take the snow off,
and steam will come out of my
compost heap.
Okay?
Which is a pretty big area and
it has not too much surface area
for a large volume,
and it maintains high
temperature right through the
winter.
Okay, now what about
evaporative water loss?
Here is a real physiological
tradeoff.
If you want to maintain your
internal temperature by cooling
yourself through evaporation,
you need a good supply of
water;
it can take a tremendous amount
of water.
As you all know,
when you get really thirsty,
running or working,
to just maintain your proper
balance of bodily fluids.
And there comes a point where
the resting metabolic rate and
the resting water loss really
get--
there's an attempt here,
with the metabolic rate
starting to go up,
that's because the water loss
is no longer able to cool the
organism enough.
So it gets up to about 42,43
Centigrade,
and this little bird is getting
into serious difficulty because
it can't evaporate enough to
hold its temperature down,
and it's starting to get up
into dangerous territory.
Okay?
Really dangerous territory.
So that's another illustration
of physiological ecology.
Let's now go to plants,
and think about water in the
soil.
Because, of course,
for plants what do they need?
Plants need sunlight,
they need water,
they need carbon dioxide;
of course they need more than
that, but if they're going to
make food, if they're going to
feed, they need sunlight,
water and carbon dioxide.
They're going to get their
water out of the soil,
and they're going to do it with
roots.
And if we look into the soil,
what we find basically is that
at a certain pore size in the
soil--
the low for certain levels of
water,
right about here,
in terms of bars.
By the way, the bars would mean
how much pressure do I have to
exert on the soil in order to
see the water come out of it?
So this would mean that I'd
have to exert a pressure of 1000
atmospheres here to squeeze any
water out of the soil.
So this would be really dry.
This would be 10 atmospheres
here.
And up here the water is
draining away freely.
So this basically is the water
which is available to the
plants.
It's between about 10
atmospheres of pressure and
about 1/10^(th) of an atmosphere
of pressure, right here.
And that's associated with
whether you're dealing with
soils which are very fine and
claylike--
so they have fine particles and
small pores--
or whether you are dealing with
soils that are gravely or sandy
or things like that.
So what the plant does is it
puts its roots down into the
soil, and it's going to suck
that water out of the soil.
Now I don't know if any of you
have ever stood on the edge of a
pool and tried to suck the water
from a swimming pool up a tube
which is only as tall as your
body;
okay, less than 2 meters.
It's hard.
Your cheeks really hurt.
And, in fact,
you can't do it very well.
Most of us can deal all right
with the level of the latte or
the milkshake,
but the swimming pool is hard.
I now want you to think about a
Redwood or a Doug fir that is
going to put its roots down into
the soil and suck that water up
100 meters.
>
It's not easy.
There has to be tremendous
negative pressure maintained,
continuously over that 100
meters, to pull that water up to
where a leaf can use it,
to combine with carbon dioxide,
using the energy from the sun,
to photosynthesize 100 meters
off the ground.
Okay? Not simple.
So how do they do it?
Well here's a leaf,
and here's the business end of
the leaf, right here,
the stoma.
There are some guard cells here
that are regulating the diameter
of the stoma.
There's carbon dioxide coming
in, and the oxygen is coming
out.
Here's the delivery system over
here.
We've got the xylem and the
phloem.
This is the vascular bundle.
And the question is,
how do they do it?
Well the transpirational pull
is being caused by the water
that evaporates inside the
leaves.
Okay?
So if we go back to this,
you should think of water that
is going to evaporate and go out
of the stoma--
and it's coming off of these
cells right here,
next to the xylem and the
phloem--and it will cause,
as the water is evaporating
from the stoma,
it will cause the water surface
in the stoma to pull back into
pores in the cell walls--
well it's not from the stoma,
it's actually from the cell,
inside the leaf--and there it
will form kind of a concave
meniscus.
But it's got very high surface
tension--and this is back to
L.J. Henderson;
water has these amazing
properties.
Water has amazing surface
tension.
Water can climb up the edge of
a glass.
Okay?
And that's caused by the
hydrogen bonds between the water
molecules.
They have this beautiful
little, kind of Y-shaped
structure, and they readily form
hydrogen bonds.
And actually liquid water is
this beautiful set of sheets of
these layers of molecules that
have formed these bonds.
So that surface tension pulls
the concavity back out.
Okay?
So the combined force that's
generated by billions of these
things is strong enough--
this should be 'lift' not
'life'--to lift water from the
roots up 100 meters.
Now if you're going to do that,
boy do you have to build a heck
of a straw;
and that's what xylem is.
Okay?
The xylem vessels that will
transport the water have to have
very small diameters.
They have to be built very
strongly,
because otherwise the water
cone is going to be broken by
cavitation,
and as soon as it's broken by
the leaves on the top dry out
and die.
So cavitation is a big problem;
that's the formation of a
bubble, inside the xylem.
Okay, that was a little bit
about the physiology of how
plants drink.
It's more complicated than
that, but I think that I have
been able at least to illustrate
the problem to you,
and I think I have shown you
that the physiological problem
posed by the environment has
been solved by the evolution of
xylem and phloem;
which happened about 3 to 400
million years ago,
and has since been perfected to
a great degree.
If you go out now and you're
doing work in the short-grass
prairie,
or in the long-grass prairie,
for that matter--
Mindy Smith works in the Kanza
Prairie in Kansas,
and in South Africa--and you do
a section through the soil,
you can see that a lot of the
life of plants,
and a lot of both their
individual ecology and their
competitive relationships with
other plants,
is actually being mediated by
where their roots are foraging
for water.
Some of them can go deep,
some of them stay shallow,
and they partition that soil
environment into different areas
that they are sucking water
from.
By the way, the earthworms are
also partitioning it.
There are some that up here and
some that are down there,
and some that move back and
forth.
So there are some organisms,
some plants,
that are really extreme
competitors.
Eucalyptus trees from
Australia, and Casuarina trees,
which come from Northern
Australia,
New Guinea and the Solomon
Islands,
have been introduced around the
world.
So I have been in a field
station in Corsica,
surrounded by Eucalyptus trees.
I've been on the Berkeley
Campus surrounded by Eucalyptus
trees.
I have been in Central Uganda,
surrounded by Eucalyptus trees.
People have just planted these
things all over the world,
and boy are they good at
sucking water out of the soil.
And, in fact,
what they'll do is they'll suck
the water table down to where
they will kill off any
competitors,
because they've just made a
desert out of the upper layer of
soil.
Casuarina does much the same
thing;
and Casuarina also has the
advantage that it can fix
nitrogen in its root nodules,
and so it can grow in places
that many other things can't.
So these things spread quite
well.
If you were to do this kind of
section,
not in a short-grass prairie,
but if you were to go into the
Kalahari Desert and look at how
far down an Acacia tree can send
its roots,
it'll go down 46 meters.
Okay?
Well 46 meters is over 150 feet
deep, down, and it's going to
suck that water up into a tree.
which is probably 20 meters
high, and in the process it's
going to drive the water table
down to where many other things
can't reach it anymore.
So these physiological
adaptations are things that not
only have consequences for the
survival and the reproduction of
the individual organisms,
they also have consequences for
everything which is living
around them,
and the ones that can do it
better hurt the ones that can't
do it so well.
If we go into the environment
of estuaries,
the plants that are growing in
estuaries,
like these mangroves,
have the problem that is
basically caused by the fact
that estuaries are one of the
most productive ecosystems on
earth.
And there's just a tremendous
amount of leaf litter,
and there are algae living in
the water,
and the leaves and the dead
algae and whatnot fall down to
the bottom and they start to
decompose,
and the bacteria that are
decomposing them use up the
oxygen.
And so if you take a sample
down, through the mud,
the soil, at the bottom of one
of these mangrove estuaries,
you will hit a layer that is
just black.
It is a very reducing
environment.
It's got hydrogen sulfide,
stinks like rotten eggs,
and if you're a root of a
plant, living down there,
you've got a problem,
because you need oxygen.
You are a multi-cellular plant,
and all of your cells have
evolved in an oxygenated
environment,
at least in your ancestors,
but now your ecology is asking
you to grow in a place where in
order to feed your plant,
you have to probe into what is
an extremely dangerous
environment;
it doesn't have any oxygen in
it.
And so mangroves have these
morphological adaptations.
Their roots stick up little
siphons--
okay, they have snorkels--so
that the roots can suck oxygen
down,
from above, and get a flow of
oxygen coming down that will
help them out.
Remember, the roots don't have
chloroplasts.
They're down in a dark
environment.
They can't make their oxygen
endogenously,
they've got to get it out of
the atmosphere.
So this is what happens.
Okay, so I've done this fairly
quickly.
But the point of it is that
both in plants and animals,
and endotherms and ectotherms,
anything you look at,
any organism,
from a virus and a bacterium,
on up to a blue whale and a
redwood,
that you look at on the face of
the earth,
is going to be loaded with
physiological and morphological
adaptations,
and these things are
determining the range of
conditions and resources under
which they can survive and
reproduce.
So if we look at that,
just as a general conceptual
problem, we can summarize it in
the form of an ecological niche.
Okay?
So if you look at the
performance of that species,
with respect to some
environmental variable--
this could be temperature or
oxygen concentration or pH--
there will be a range of that
environmental variable within
which the organism can
reproduce,
there'll be a slightly broader
range within which it can grow,
and there will be an even
broader range within which it
can survive.
So it can explore parts of the
environment within which it
cannot grow, and it can grow in
parts of the environment within
which it cannot reproduce.
But there will be a core where
life is easy and it can carry
out its lifecycle.
For example,
here's a two-dimensional niche.
This one is just measuring
survival.
So these are actually
experimental data.
This is salinity down here and
temperature over here.
And it's for a sand shrimp,
Crangon.
And basically what this is
telling you is that it has zero
mortality in a salinity range of
about two-thirds sea water,
up to slightly over full sea
water.
This is full sea water right
here, about 35 parts per
thousand.
And up here it's showing you
that it will start hitting some
mortality at about 25,
and some mortality at about 10.
Okay?
So you could imagine carrying
this process further,
putting a third dimension on,
putting a fourth dimension on,
and having the organism tell
you in what part of the
potential range of conditions on
the planet can it live.
And there are interactions--I
mean, an interaction will be any
time there's a curve in the
slope here.
Okay?
So the range of salinities at
which it has no mortality is
affected,
to a certain,
and in this case fairly slight
degree,
by the range of temperatures.
So the niche is an
N-dimensional hyper-volume.
We just saw a two-dimensional
one here, and I told you that
could be extended to three,
four, five, ten,
however many you wanted to pack
on.
That is a mental tool,
and it was invented by humans,
actually in this building,
to understand how organisms
evolve to deal with
environmental problems.
Okay?
So it's an attempt to extract
key features.
You can think of those
dimensions both as abiotic and
as biotic.
So the abiotic ones usually are
things like temperature,
salinity, humidity,
oxygen, carbon dioxide,
pH.
The biotic ones are predators,
competitors,
pathogens, mutualists;
and the biotic ones co-evolve.
Okay?
So the niche of one species is
going to be co-evolving with the
niche of another species.
So you should think of these
things as changing through
evolutionary time.
All the biological evolution in
the world isn't going to do very
much to the distribution of
temperature on the planet.
So it's not as though the
biotic variables are going to be
causing a co-evolutionary
response in the abiotic ones;
they won't.
Those things are just things
that are imposed on the process.
But if you have a predator/prey
interaction,
or a parasite/host interaction,
or two competitors dealing with
each other,
the area of the niche
hyper-volume,
within which each of them can
reproduce and survive,
is going to be changed by their
co-evolution.
So what that means is that
niches aren't pre-existing
molds, out there,
into which organisms are
poured.
They are the products of an
evolutionary play that is
creating the theater while it's
writing the roles.
And while the play is running,
evolution is rewriting the
script,
it's remodeling the actors,
it's putting in new actors,
it's redesigning the sets,
and it's renovating the
theater.
It's a very long running play,
it's got a lot of characters.
So if you think of a niche as
static, essentially what you're
doing is you're just taking a
snapshot out of a video,
or a snapshot out of a film.
Okay?
They're really dynamic things.
Okay next week,
next time, we will start with
population growth and the issue
of what density does to
population growth.